From method acting madness to weird food
choices to the place Johnny Galecki stuck
all of his used chewing gum, these actors
had some seriously gross on-set habits.
When Robert Pattinson landed the role of
Edward Cullen in the Twilight franchise,
he entered the realm of sudden
superstardom. He also developed
a reputation for having poor hygiene. A
source on the set of New Moon told E! News,
"He stinks. I mean, it's awful. He never showers,
and it drives people on the set
crazy. [...] He completely reeks."
"P.U. It is ripe in here."
Not everyone associated with Twilight
complained about Pattinson's smell.
Kristen Stewart told People,
"He smells great. [...] It's kind of an animalist
thing that goes on. It went along
with the movie, so it was perfect."
When Extra asked Pattinson about
not washing his hair for six weeks,
Pattinson made a shocking admission, saying,
"If you don't care if your hair is clean
or not, then why would you wash it?"
Not to worry — becoming a model for Dior
helped Pattinson clean up his act. In 2014,
he told The Wall Street Journal,
"I can't tell if it's because of my
association with Dior or because I'm older,
but I've started moisturizing. It's been
a quite profound change in my life."
His co-stars must appreciate him
arriving on set fresh and clean.
Brad Pitt has long been a sex symbol.
He's been crowned People's Sexiest Man
Alive twice. But the star is also
famous for having poor hygiene.
"Say it ain't so!"
Pitt readily admits to not showering
regularly but insists baby wipes keep
him fresh. His Inglourious Basterds
co-star, Eli Roth, told People,
"After a scene, Brad had to get next to me
for a close-up shot, and he said, 'Damn,
you're ripe.' I said, 'I didn't have time to
shower.' He said, 'Baby wipes, man, baby wipes.'"
Pitt also stopped using soap and antiperspirant
because of concerns for the environment and the
toxins the products contain, opting for a homemade
concoction. Not everyone was as impressed as Roth
was with Pitt's hygiene hack. Even Pitt's children
have staged a mutiny over his insufficient bathing
habits. If his family is complaining, can
you imagine what his co-stars have to say?
Pitt isn't alone in his aversion to soap, bathing,
and deodorant. Many stars have come out in recent
years as being infrequent bathers. Mila Kunis and
Ashton Kutcher talked about their relaxed approach
to bathing with Dax Shepard on the Armchair Expert
podcast. And Jake Gyllenhaal told Vanity Fair,
"More and more I find bathing
to be less necessary."
Shia LaBeouf doesn't claim to be a method
actor, but, while filming the war epic Fury,
the cast and crew were troubled by the
extreme methods he used to get into character.
LaBeouf told Dazed Digital that after landing the
role he trained with the 41st Infantry
of the US National Guard. He admitted,
"I pulled my tooth out, knifed my face up,
and spent days watching horses die.
I didn't bathe for four months."
"It seems wild 'cause it's a scar but
you get a lotta scars doing these things.
Moreso emotionally than the physical stuff.
That's really the smallest part of the job."
A source told The Daily Mail,
"Shia was warned about his
behavior by several people on set,
including Brad Pitt and director David Ayer."
You read that right, even Pitt was offended
by LaBeouf's poor hygiene and self-mutilation.
According to The Daily Mail, he even wound
up staying in a different lodging than
the rest of the cast and crew because of
his poor hygiene and troubling behavior.
Jim Carrey's bizarre and annoying antics on
the set of Man on the Moon were so strange,
Universal didn't want any behind-the-scenes
footage released. In Chris Smith's Netflix
documentary Jim & Andy: The Great Beyond,
audiences saw this footage for the first time.
"It's really weird. It's totally surreal."
While making Miloš Forman's biopic about
the eccentric comedian Andy Kaufman,
Carrey got lost in the role, staying in
character on set for four months of filming.
In the documentary, Carrey
says that when he got the role,
Kaufman's spirit tapped him
on the shoulder and took over.
"What happened afterwards was out of my control."
Carrey certainly seems possessed by
something, and it wasn't always fun
for the cast and crew. For example, Carrey
made everyone on set call him Andy — or Tony,
when Carrey inhabited Kaufman's
belligerent alter ego, Tony Clifton.
He was combative and rude, especially with
Jerry Lawler, the professional wrestler
who plays himself in the film, going so
far as to spit in his face. Ultimately,
Carrey won a Golden Globe for his
performance, but for the cast and crew,
Carrey's method acting was unprofessional
and disruptive to the production.
In 2005, when Matthew McConaughey was named
People's Sexiest Man Alive, he told the world,
"I haven't worn deodorant in 20 years."
McConaughey's stance isn't
driven by health concerns;
the actor just doesn't think it's necessary. In
a 2008 interview with Playboy, McConaughey said,
"The women in my life, including
my mother, have all said, 'Hey,
your natural smell smells, one, like
a man, and, two, smells like you.'"
That is, until he worked with Kate
Hudson, who begged him to use her
natural deodorant while filming Fool's
Gold. McConaughey explained to Playboy,
"She always brings a salt rock,
which is some natural deodorant,
and says, 'Would you please put this on?'"
Apparently, others have worked with McConaughey
and found absolutely nothing offensive
about his smell. Yvette Nicole Brown,
who worked with the actor on Tropic Thunder, told
The Jess Cagle Show he actually smelled good.
"He smells like granola and good livin'."
It must have been extra hot in Australia while
filming Fool's Gold, or maybe McConaughey started
taking multiple showers every day. Either way, he
and Hudson have made a couple of films together,
and they had great screen chemistry
— even if she thought he smelled bad.
Shailene Woodley is known for being
health-conscious and into natural
healing and natural beauty products, but
one of her co-stars didn't appreciate
her herbalism. Miles Teller said he
hated kissing her while filming The
Spectacular Now because her numerous herbal
tinctures tasted bad. Teller told Vulture,
"She would take these herbal supplements,
these Chinese herbal supplements,
and they tasted like crap. And she would always
eat them right before we had a kissing scene!"
Woodley didn't enjoy shooting their kissing
scenes either. Reportedly she took issue
with Teller's breath, too. Woodley told Vulture,
"We'd have to kiss in a scene, and he'd be like,
'Shay, you just ate dirt.' And I'd be like,
'Miles, you just ate licorice.' It
was just this ongoing back-and-forth."
"You stink."
"No, you stink."
This might surprise fans who have seen Woodley and
Teller in four films together. But don't worry,
this popular film duo are friends despite their
complaints about each other's on-set habits.
Woodley also apparently loved
Teller's recent work in Top Gun:
Maverick, telling People that Teller
is a, quote, "wildly talented actor."
Although Teller appreciated the
praise, he told the publication,
"She certainly didn't have to do anything
publicly for me to know that she supports me
and that we are really good friends. [...]
We've been very close for a long time."
Maybe next time they meet up to play
romantic leads, they can just agree on
breath mints or a universally inoffensive
glass of water before kissing scenes.
Word is Jennifer Lawrence, quote, "tortured" her
Hunger Games leading men by eating stinky food
before her kissing scenes with both
Liam Hemsworth and Josh Hutcherson,
and she didn't feel bad about it one bit.
Lawrence confirmed this on The Graham Norton Show.
"Whenever I had to kiss Josh
and Liam for The Hunger Games,
who cares. I'd eat like mustard
and tuna — like who cares?"
Hemsworth had his chance to
complain about Lawrence's
gross on-set food choices to Jimmy Fallon.
"Anytime I had to kiss Jennifer was
pretty uncomfortable. Pretty awkward."
When Fallon was baffled by this
declaration, Hemsworth explained,
"She's one of my best friends. I love
her. But if we had a kissing scene,
she would make a point of
eating garlic or tuna fish."
Not to worry — these two are clearly friends
who enjoy giving each other a hard time.
From stories that surfaced about the practical
jokes and pranks pulled during production of the
Hunger Games movies, it seems like Lawrence's food
choices were more of a joke than poor hygiene or
a deliberate tactic to torment her leading men.
And the men occasionally fought back. Hutcherson
once scared Lawrence so badly that she peed
her pants when he put a mutilated dummy in
the bathroom of her trailer. If you're going to
dish it out, you'd better learn to take it, right?
Jason Segel was a smoker when he landed a
starring role on the hit series How I Met
Your Mother. Reportedly, his co-star and on-screen
wife, Alyson Hannigan, told him she wouldn't do
any kissing scenes with him because of his
smoker's breath. Hannigan told Digital Spy,
"I cannot stand cigarette smoke.
It's like kissing an ashtray and
he's trying to be polite by having
gum or mints, but it doesn't help."
According to Hannigan, the pair
developed a system. She explained,
"When we started the pilot he was
like, 'Get me to stop smoking,
I'll be your best friend'. So we
did this bet where he would owe
me $10 every time he had a cigarette.
After the first day, he owed me $200.'"
Fortunately, Segel quit,
but it only lasted a year,
after which stress got him started again.
But despite being grossed out by his smoking,
Hannigan loved working with Segal on the series.
She broke down crying while trying to explain why
she would miss him during a cast reunion on The
Talk. And the feelings were obviously mutual.
"Aly taught me a lot about how to be a man,
I gotta say. I was 25 when I took the show,
and I think we've all been
through a lot personally."
It goes to show that just because
an actor has a gross on-set habit,
it doesn't mean their co-stars
won't grow to love them.
Allegedly, Arnold Schwarzenegger intentionally
farted in the face of one of his co-stars.
Miriam Margolyes is probably best known for
playing Professor Sprout in Harry Potter and
Juliet's nurse in Baz Luhrmann's iconic film
Romeo + Juliet. Her hilarious and brutally
honest answers to interview questions have made
her a popular and entertaining talk show guest.
The British actor told I've Got News For You
that she didn't enjoy meeting Schwarzenegger
while filming the horror movie End of Days,
and she hasn't gotten over it, saying,
"He's a bit too full of himself, and I don't
care for him at all. He's a Republican,
which I don't like. He was actually quite rude.
He farted in my face. Now, I fart. Of course
I do — but I don't fart in people's faces.
He did it deliberately, right in my face."
Not only was this on-set behavior gross, but
Margolyes also found it offensive, saying,
"I was playing Satan's sister, and
he was killing me, so he had me in
a position where I couldn't escape and
lying on the floor. And he just farted."
Despite Variety reaching out to
Schwarzenegger's representatives
for comment, it appears the actor
has never addressed her accusation.
Johnny Galecki's unhygienic habit of disposing
of his gum on the set of The Big Bang Theory was
so gross one of his co-stars couldn't resist
talking about it. If you're familiar with the
comedy series, you know the elevator in the
apartment building where Sheldon, Leonard,
and Penny lived remained out of order for years on
end. Kunal Nayyar, who played Raj Koothrappali on
the series, revealed to Daily Express that
the on-set stairs led to nowhere, saying,
"There's a wall there where Johnny Galecki,
for 12 years, would stick his chewing gum on.
I'm not joking; there's a wall of 3,000
dried chewing gum from Johnny Galecki."
This is a totally gross on-set habit,
but do you know what's even more disgusting?
Some fans would probably spend a pretty penny
to buy that wall of chewing gum as a
weird piece of celebrity memorabilia.